[Music]
[Applause]
I've been saying this over the last 48
hours and I'm not a sky's falling guy
but you know we're we're on the verge of
something changing college football and
I don't know how much but it feels like
it's going to be reshaped here or at
least we're on the verge of this and
John Canzano a great columnist
johncanzano.com radio host on 7 50 a.m
in Portland and certainly covering the
Pac-12 uh and I wanted to have you on
because I don't know if you feel this
same way John but it feels like the
Pac-12 is in Peril and the question is
what can you do so where where do we
stand now uh 11 30 a.m Eastern
yeah last night uh I think everybody was
sending out the amber alert and and
really looking at the Arizona schools
Arizona Arizona state anytime the
Regents meet uh there's buzz buzz
buzzing in the Pac-12 footprint and
they're they're going to meet later
today tonight early this evening and I
think a lot of people last night
expected that Arizona and Arizona state
would leave the conference I reached out
to a member of the Pac-12 CEO group this
morning who told me that there was some
enthusiasm internally with the Pac-12
now I'm I'm pumping the brakes I'm
rolling my eyes a little bit because
I've heard this all throughout this
negotiation but uh what I was told is
that the Arizona schools are really
looking hard at the University of Oregon
today Oregon is expected to get a
reduced share invitation to the Big Ten
Conference could come as soon as this
morning midday today you know we know
that the Big Ten has opened that that
conversation internally and I think
there's a lot of eyes on Oregon Oregon
appears to be the glue right now now in
the conference because the Arizona
schools are saying that if Oregon stays
if Oregon chooses to stay in the Pac-12
there might be something there for the
Arizona schools that media deal that
George kuyofkov finally presented
earlier this week I think was
underwhelming to a lot of people from a
financial standpoint it appears that
there seems to be now maybe an added
layer to this I don't know I don't know
if more money came in I don't know if a
new partner came in but you know I was
told that a big part of this now hinges
on the University of Oregon
and you know Phil Knight has his money
behind you know the Oregon program I
don't know how much of an enticement the
Big Ten saying hey come over here you
can make this amount of money plus if
you're Oregon don't you look at this and
say this opens the door with UCLA or
certainly USC out the door that we can
qualify right now for the national champ
we can win the Pac-12 no matter who's
still left this is an easier path than
if we go to Big Ten yeah Oregon is such
an interesting figure here because
they're not like others they're not like
the other Pac-12 Schools they're not
like a lot of the universities
nationally they have thrived at a time
when the other Pac-12 schools were
underfunded you know because of Phil and
Penny night you know I reached out to
Phil Knight earlier this week and the
response I got back is that he wasn't
ready to talk because he was going to
say something he might regret you know
and I was like that's the ideal time
exactly
but but you're right you're absolutely
right Rob Mullins the athletic director
at Oregon he told me multiple times uh
just a week ago told me that access to
the playoff is what matters to the Ducks
and now the University of Washington
looks over at Oregon they want to be
alongside Oregon and if Arizona and
Arizona state do uh if they're being
real about wanting to be in this
conference and I think or the decision
really comes down to the next 24 to 36
hours with the Oregon Ducks will they
decide that they're better off not
competing against Ohio State Michigan
and Penn State and everybody in USC and
UCLA and the Big Ten and and having an
easier path to the playoff or will they
take uh you know what everyone thinks is
the future of college football and jump
to a conference of 18 or 20. how'd the
Pac-12 get here sure
let's let's go back I mean 10 12 years
Larry Scott the commissioner of the
Pac-12 he did some good things early but
his media deal was outdated they never
should have been a media company they
tried to own and operate the Pac-12
networks they should have had a media
partner uh we all know now that
television is running the show in
college football it's really unfortunate
to see what TV has done to tradition and
kickoff times and rivalries and uh you
know the the bifurcation of all the
conferences the you know the fox can say
all they want that that you know hey
we're not behind all of this but the
money is there and we all know what's
driving all of the expansion and the
realignment but I think the Pac-12 made
some terrible miscues in the Larry Scott
era I think George kyovkov came through
the door he should have been more tuned
in to UCLA and USC being unhappy that
should have been job one
um even if they're they're telling you
your face they're hap hey we're happy
we're good here he should have been
camping in the front yard at USC and
making sure of it and and then you know
I think the media landscape has shifted
we've all seen the layoffs and we've
seen that industry hit hard and I think
it's a terrible time to be negotiating I
think it's just it's really unfortunate
for the Pac-12 and Pac-12 fans more
importantly
yeah I thought Arizona it felt like
Arizona Arizona State are waiting for
somebody else some other school to
secede from the union then they can go
to the big 12. so if Washington and
Oregon said you know we're going to the
Big Ten then Arizona Arizona state would
go well we're going to the big 12. but
I'm also wondering who do they add
because I was told all along San Diego
State was joining us you know they were
they were joining the Pac-12 uh I was
told you know Boise the other sort of a
novelty that wouldn't happen SMU was you
know a possibility so can the Big 12 if
they lose schools reshape and still be
the the Pac-12
yeah the the the the easiest thing today
would be hey they hold at nine they add
San Diego State um you know I did
inquire you know how how would the 34
million dollar uh exit fee at the
Mountain West Conference work I was told
that there's some Financial flexibility
that the Pac-12 would offer there maybe
they subsidize it maybe uh you know San
Diego State takes a lower distribution
as they enter the conference I was also
told from a Mountain West Conference
president that the Mountain West might
be willing to negotiate that nobody
wants to end up in litigation over these
things they're all negotiable even
though 34 million dollars is the number
that's your starting point I think you
could get there but um you know the the
easiest answer is stay at nine add San
Diego State but it becomes critical
today if you lose Oregon you're going to
lose Washington and you're going to lose
the Arizona schools and you have to be
able to trust each other at a time when
nobody can trust each other Dan they're
all Pirates they're all Pirates and
they're playing chess unfortunately
great to talk to you as always John
thank you thank you that's John Canzano
columnist and radio host at 7 50 a.m in
Portland